[Music]
nick wright joins us on loan from first
things first the popular co-host on fox
sports 1.
nick
what do you think of steph curry this
season
all these steph curry questions
uh
in
in all seriousness it's been sensational
i mean he's been sensational i've gotta
let me ask you a question dan yep going
into this year if somewhere to ask you
all-time great all-time pyramid who's
ahead stepper k-date who do you have
higher
i would take stuff
oh so you would have already had steph
higher because i think most people even
though steph has one more ring and one
more league mvp i think particularly
after the playoffs last year would have
said kd's a tick above
if the warriors win the title this year
though
you have to like it the steph kd debate
at least for the time being stops being
a debate steph would have double the
mvps and double the rings all of that
and you start to reevaluate like where
is steph historically i mean i think
he's right now
knocking on the door of the top 15 all
time
but they win the title this year
he probably also would win the league
mvp this year if they win 60 plus games
he he starts kicking that door in and
moving past guys like a team
past guys like dr j like obviously
pastor ant i i think it's a really
special thing because i thought the
warriors were done winning titles and
now the door is back open for them i
asked dwayne wade about that yesterday
and he said he would take steph because
he changed the game
and
i mean think about the most influential
people who've ever played this game
and steps on the short list of most
influential players
in the history there's no
there's no doubt about that as far as
influence he is
i want to say top five all time but that
does you know he's far more influential
than tim duncan but tim duncan had the
better career but
if they win the title this year steph
starts really approaching
the hollowed hollowed ground
top ten though nick if i said at the end
of their careers katie or steph more
likely to go in to the top ten
so i would have
honestly and i don't want to be too
reactionary
a month ago i would have said kd
because i thought steph is steph was had
an mvp level season last year dan and
the warriors missed the playoffs so i'm
like okay so steph's not going to play
in the finals again
but if they if they make the finals this
year if they win the title
then you then to me it'd be steph if if
this is more about schedule and maybe
when clay comes back he's not the guy we
think he's going to be and the warriors
are a second round exit
kd
because
you know he's bigger i think he i don't
i don't know if you can say he scores
more effortlessly but it does feel like
he can do a little more but again like
those are i mean you're a basketball
historian like me so that to me take
there's four guys that are almost like
you know the older older generation
russell wilt oscar and west they've got
to be included but they almost have to
be included separately you know like a
veterans committee and then people can
argue about the order but i don't think
many people would argue about this next
nine lebron kareem michael magic duncan
kobe bird akeem shaq so now we're at
nine plus the four there's thirteen
i would have had dr j and moses
rounding out my top fifteen with steph
and kd ready to knock one of them out
but how high can either one of them
climb can they pass bird
can they you know i think they both can
pass dr j and moses
but so there's you know at some point
there is there a ceiling i don't know
like it it's a hard this is what people
do when the top 75 list comes out
they're like this guy's a top 20 guy all
time it's like no he's not like there's
you got to list the names and so it just
but i'm starting to reconsider how high
steph can climb
i liked golden state last year to go to
the nba finals and i certainly like them
this year um
they have youth
they're going to get clay back
and it just feels like the west is a
little bit vulnerable because i don't
know what to expect out of the lakers
you know can the f can phoenix do it
again and what did they learn last year
denver can you count on them to be
consistent enough to play at a high
level utah are they going to be in there
as well
you toss you tell us out utah never gets
to be talked as a playoff team again
they're out and as i understand that all
the and i'm an analytics guy all the
analytics folks have explained to me
that nikola yokic is maybe the greatest
player in the history of the league was
really fascinating because none of them
believe that nuggets are going to make
the finals the nba is pretty simple if
you have the best player in the league
you're probably going to win the
championship nobody thinks nuggets can
win the championship so miss me with
this jokic is better than giannis mess i
don't care what the numbers say i watch
the games the but yes the the west is
open and here you said they have youth
here's the other thing the warriors have
going for so they're getting clay back
that'll be an infusion no matter what
form he's in he'll help yeah they also
though
they're getting nothing right wiseman's
not playing yet and kaminga and moody
are so young like 18 and 19 when you
draft them
if they want
to package weissman kaminga moody
you get an all-star yeah like beale's
not going to be available now because
the warriors i'm sorry the wizards are
too good but whatever disgruntled
all-star x that you want but wouldn't i
go after buddy healed i mean i can't get
beale
what about buddy healed
well if the question there is my i know
everyone killed the lakers for not
getting buddy healed so
and i like buddy a lot but he's also
damn near 30. we don't think of that he
was old when he came out of college he's
not damn near 30 but he's late 20s
and
it's always tough for me like a guy
people so ben simmons like ben simmons
can't play in the playoffs but he's been
in the playoffs like maybe buddy can't
either like buddy's the sixth man on the
kings like i i like buddy a lot but i i
i like ben simmons to the warriors you
don't need more shooting once you get
draymond oh i thought i'm sorry once you
get clay but don't i have to give up
draymond to make ben work with golden
state
i don't know that's what everybody says
but when the warriors won 73 games
festus zazili and maurice spates were on
the court with draymond
like i remember it because lebron was
dotting threes over poor festus's eye in
game seven like the
yeah bestest i mean bogut and the bogut
obviously was a good player but bogan
and draymond played together so like the
idea that you couldn't have draymond on
the court with another non-shooter now
draymond back then was a better shooter
than he is now so that's that's part of
it but
whoever the person is my point is if the
warriors want they can go get another
piece because they're not getting
anything from those young guys and
they're still awesome we're talking to
nick wright uh first things first
co-host on fox sports one uh how patient
are you gonna be with the lakers
well here's the deal so there's there's
the russ angle and there's a lebron part
the russ angle is first three months in
houston he was terrible and then he was
excellent end of the season same exact
thing happened with washington so i will
be patient with that and russ here's a
fun thing to look at
the best center russ has ever played
with best big russ has ever played with
young stephen adams he's never played
with a quality offensive center or
offensive big so it's going to take time
for him in anthony davis but the fact of
the matter for the lakers is this
if lebron's not still able to be a top
three at a minimum top three player in
the league
when the playoffs roll around for the
entirety of players lakers is screwed
i think he still can be i think he's got
one more of those runs in it
if if he is then again who are we taking
in the west over a fully functional hand
on the joystick lebron plus a d and i i
believe lebron is a problem solver will
make it work with russ
but
the first thing they got to do is just
get rid of their centers you can't play
ross and a center you might actually
play russ at center that's kind of what
the rockets did and it worked like a.d
you don't want to play center fine you
can be the power forward russ will be
the center and then you can spread the
floor and have more shooting there
i never understood a.d not wanting to
play center
because it feels like you have a better
chance of making the all-nba team as a
center because rudy gobert makes it
every single year yeah that you know
these bonuses come with
being first second third team
i'd want to be a center
just list me as a center who cares
yeah i
listen ads awesome
he you know
he's what's the word delicate
delicate i think is the white and nice
way to put it i just think you guys
later is that a polite soft
i didn't say soft dan i wouldn't say
that about a fellow clutch client that'd
be rude
um
i i just think he's not
as big of a fan as the contact and you
know
and he is a guy
who when he gets dinged it does appear
he's been shot but luckily he recovers
from that quickly brittle and so yeah
brittle did you call him brian yeah
i
i like delicate i'm going to stick with
the word i use hey can i i got another
question okay
were you shocked
that there were mvp chants for someone
not on the nets at barclays last night
like that doesn't happen
well
that's not really a home advantage
that's not a home fan base i mean it's a
recent fan base i mean it's
you know that's why if they won the
title they'd get a nice little parade if
the knicks win a first round
series
you know guys
topless in the streets there i mean come
on
that's absolutely right nobody cares um
a couple other things i i know that uh
the chiefs are are back
according to people i didn't know they
left but they're back and i know you're
a big kansas city chiefs fan so
would you give your logic of
are the chiefs on the short list of
teams to beat still in the nfl oh
a hundred percent listen top five
let me put it like this i think they're
the team to beat in the afc the five
best teams might all be in the nfc they
gotta beat each other like right now if
you were able to
draft your playoff opponents
like if that's the one seed got to pick
its opponents
wouldn't the chiefs be everyone's last
pick
aren't they still the team in the afc
nobody wants to face if david henry was
playing tennessee would be that team
that i would not want to play
uh sure but he's not yeah like that's
the
he's not yeah and the the bills have
been
that jags lost looms large to me for the
bills and the the bills to me are the
other dangerous team when everything's
rolling but the afc screwed up man for
the first five weeks the chiefs had
historically bad defense for the next
three weeks mahomes had the first slump
of his career and now all of a sudden we
sit here and it's like oh
they have the second most wins in the
conference like if you were ever going
to create separation would have been
this year and the afc didn't take
advantage
yeah you're right about you don't want
to face them when it gets into the
postseason
uh you know buffalo still not quite sure
like the afc right now just
not sure with anybody me neither i mean
tennessee has done everything you want a
a great team to do
we just don't recognize them as being
great
yeah it's yeah because here's the thing
because and i know that football's
complicated and it's all three phases
and all this and then at the end of the
day
before you bet your hard-earned money on
a team to win a super bowl you're like
wait
ryan tan hill's their quarterback nah
i'm gonna have to pass
they're like no he's the highest rated
passer on third downs unless he's like
yeah yeah i mean i'm not gonna do that
hey uh you're all in on
crypto.com instead of staples you're
gonna refer to i don't care man i listen
i i had an opportunity to be dan patrick
rich if i would have listened to all my
poker player friends five years ago and
bought
bitcoin and ethereum and instead i
didn't and so now i'm just hoping it all
tanks because all my friends i gamble
with are just stupid rich and i'm still
coming on these
doing this so you send me free
sweatshirts so i mean yeah so i i'm anti
i it's just total bitterness and anger
what's arrowhead called now
g-e-h-a field
i don't even know what the hell that is
i don't know what's going on yeah that's
that's great i don't know anybody who
calls it that it feels like people are
still gonna call staples staples
yeah i i heard what you guys were saying
about the winston cup before yeah so i
grew up my whole childhood was the
winston cup and i had no idea it was
about the cigarettes
i thought it was named after some famous
nascar dude named winston like when they
changed it i was so
confused i swear to god i thought that i
didn't even know and you thought that
there was a guy named nextel like that
too well no that's what i figured out
this is where i figured it out i was
like oh it's branding yeah by the way
speaking of branding is your guys show
branding these days trying to just make
anyone under 30 not understand what
you're talking about because i think
right before i came on you were like hey
fun fact about wilford brimley and
cocoon yep and i'm 37
and i've never seen cocoon like what's
the median age of people that are like
oh yeah i can picture wilford brimley
and cocoon in my head
46 but it might make you go hmm
wonder what wilford brimley looked like
at age 50 dan brought it up and he is a
hall of famer i should listen to what
dan has to say then they google and they
go oh my god boy that's a brilliant
uh announcement maybe it's there yeah or
maybe they maybe they pull out their
phone phones and say i can't find
wilford brimley on tick-tock i don't
know what the hell dan's talking yeah
maybe that maybe they just go you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna wait for colin
to come on or jim rome to come on and
then i'll listen to those programs
oh wow wow we're going
i wouldn't have said that i mean
i mean i would have thought it but i
wouldn't have said that to be rude on
your show that's okay that's okay let me
be rude to me before you're rude to me
yeah it's a good idea still waiting for
that fishing invite back yeah let's go
let's go to a game let's go to a
brooklyn nets game
plenty of scenes still available plenty
it's seven dollars
i can get in and play for 12. that's
what's great
i'm joe harris man
they could have used you last night tell
you that much buddy yeah i know uh hey
thank you thanks for joining us we
appreciate it absolutely i'll see you
soon that's uh nick wright first things
first cohort co
i think i called him a co-ho a co-host
cohort
host on fox sports one